we are back with Chris Pratt Charlie Day
Keegan Michael Key and Jack Black Give
It All
learn a movie it's called the Super
Mario Brothers movie it's in theaters
everywhere in April all right well Chris
you had a run-in um with bees since I
saw you last it was a very funny video
um online so tell everybody what
happened there's this wonderful uh
person on Instagram I I wish I knew that
it's Texas B lady or something of course
she's from Texas please when you if she
of course when you I want to give her
the credit that it's due she's fantastic
I love watching her on Instagram you
guys follow this gal she like has the
most amazing demeanor I can't think of
her name right now so put it on the
screen or something it's this this is
her name
she's like very calm in her voice and
she's like uh today I saw a hive of bees
in the Floor of a baseball Dugout and
she takes out the floor and there's like
four million bees she knows she just
reaches in there with her hands and
they're all over her and she's like
finds the queen and puts it in the hair
clip I'll watch I'd go on a like a k
hole of this B lady for like four hours
watching her video she's been fantastic
and they let her touch the queen it
didn't no and then she'll put it away
and then she moves them all they just
love her they never sting her she's cool
so I of course watched four hours these
videos I'm like I got this down and so
there was a we were you know looking at
a house uh this house that was for sale
we went to go tour it and just like to
uh saw this big big like beehive in the
real estate agent was like Hey careful
there's a big beehive over there I'm
like
we're okay
I was like yeah they do look like
honeybees
[Laughter]
I was like trust me if you're calm they
won't
stung me right in the eyeball like right
here I was like
and so um there it is you can see my eye
there
um she got me good and then and then she
and then I was like I think I may have
jokingly said like B lady in the video
and then she uh roasted me in the
comments section and anyways we're kind
of friends oh my God
no I don't know and she I she after
roasting me she hasn't returned my calls
but it's fine she seems give her a
follow she's actually really fantastic
she's a really cool guy I do think it's
incredible when people do stuff like
that oh my gosh yeah but she should say
don't try this at home
please don't follow any like snake or
bear people yeah
you're like the little boy that like
watched Peter Pan were like watch this
moment oh I have an umbrella
maybe Poppins did it yeah that's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
home
[Music]